nearly a week after the rush tragedy
major developments today on the
investigation into what happened on set
at a press conference today
does alex baldwin himself face the
potential of criminal charges
all options are on the table at this
point no one has been ruled out at this
point
he's obviously the person that fired the
weapon so right now he is an active part
of this investigation
alec baldwin obviously did not intend to
shoot a live round or to kill her i
think the most he could be charged with
is a negligent homicide and yes that is
a possibility because he did not check
the gun before he fired but a jury would
be asked should he or should he rely on
the assistant director that hands him
the gun there's also another level of
responsibility because baldwin is also a
producer on the movie rust
new details revealed today authorities
believe alec fired a 45 caliber colt
pistol like this one and shot a live
lead bullet accidentally killing
cinematographer helena hutchins the
projectile was removed from the shoulder
of rust director joel souza who was
briefly hospitalized and we're learning
more about the investigation according
to this search warrant obtained by et
authorities say they recovered three
revolvers and a startling amount of
evidence there was a total of 500 rounds
of ammunition that is a mix of blanks
dummy rounds and what we are suspecting
live rounds
live rounds and movie sets
don't
mix fox nation's nancy grace told et the
investigation will take months and it's
pretty surprising to have real ammo on
the set that is why there are so many
layers of precaution for movies of this
genre a western with a lot of guns and a
lot of ammo and a lot of shoot them out
you have to be careful
by the way the sheriff's statement about
live rounds seems to contradict what
armorer hannah gutierrez-reid allegedly
told investigators according to a
warrant she claimed quote no live ammo
is ever kept on set other reports
sloppy work cutting corners negligence
on the set especially when it comes to
weapons
can come before a jury
because it sets the tone of what
happened leading up to helena's death
i think there was some complacency on
this set and i think there are some
safety issues that need to be addressed
by the industry and possibly by the
state of new mexico also emerging today
clarity about the video evidence seized
there was camera footage but i can say
that there was no footage of the actual
incident nbc news reports they viewed
onset video from before the accident it
shows an actor not armor or hana handing
alex 15-year-old co-star brady noon a
long gun during rehearsal which experts
say violates industry protocol was this
because of budget to save money rush the
job is that why helena is dead leaving
behind a husband and a child rust was
the 24 year old second movie ever two
months ago was her first the old way
starring nicholas cage she spoke about
it on a recent podcast i was really
nervous about it at first and i almost
didn't take the job because i wasn't
sure if i was ready there are now other
reports emerging that nicholas cage
walked off a movie set because the very
same armorer was firing guns on the set
if that's true nicholas cage could very
well be called to testify someone else
who could be at fault david paul the
assistant director who apparently was
fired from a previous movie for another
gun mishap that cannot be ignored
he's supposed to check the gun she's
responsible
a detective claims dave halls admitted
to errors in gun safety protocol
including not checking all of the
chambers before handing the gun to
baldwin the official also says halls
couldn't recall if gutierrez reed spun
the drum as is standard practice there
will be multiple losses probably against
alec baldwin and many others russ
producers have opened their own
investigation and so is attorney gloria
allred who's representing the film's
script supervisor mimi mitchell who
called 9-1-1 we were rehearsing and it
went off and i ran out she was standing
very close to helena safety protocols
were clearly not followed it was clearly
at the minimum gross civil negligence
gloria allred is now on the case you can
bet your bottom dollar there's going to
be a lawsuit
[Music]